donald trump gibt sich zu spekulationen
über eine präsidentschaftskandidatur von
oprah winfrey gelassen
er könne sie besiegen sagte der us
präsident am dienstag vor journalisten
opera wäre ein großer spaß ich kenne sie
sehr gut ich mag sie sagte trump er
glaube aber nicht dass sie kandidiere
auch eine vertraute der us
fernsehmoderatoren erklärte winfrey sei
zwar von der idee einer kandidatur
fasziniert erwäge den schritt derzeit
aber nicht die 63 jährige wurde im
internet als potenzielle gegenkandidaten
zu trump gehandelt nachdem sie bei der
golden-globe-verleihung für frauen und
bürgerrechte geworben hatte
die nächste us präsidentenwahl steht
2020 an